[Music]
jackass is a global phenomenon but if
johnny knoxville had gotten his way he
might not have lived to see its great
success here's how the jackass superstar
was stopped from blowing his own guts
out
it's safe to say that the age-old lesson
of knowing your limits was never
entirely understood by the jackass crew
in their latest big screen outing
jackass forever johnny knoxville and the
rest of his team were back breaking
limits and themselves for our
entertainment however it seems that this
was the installment that finally gave
knoxville the wake-up call he needed
albeit one he received from the comfort
of an ambulance stretcher he's getting
better he's coming too
yeah
all right that was a violent brawl
one-sided
following filming knoxville admitted
that he was ending his stunt career
after suffering severe injuries
including a brain hemorrhage for the
film
after taking that major hit during the
movie's bull stunt it was a reassuring
revelation that he was finally calling
it a day speaking to variety during the
release of jackass forever the stunt
star admitted my family doesn't like me
doing this type of thing this is the
most wicked bull hit i've ever taken
while turning down another round with a
bull seems like a no-brainer there were
far more deadly plans that never came to
fruition in the early years of jackass
director and producer jeff tremaine
recalled one idea he thankfully thwarted
which could have taken out knoxville for
good during an appearance on the nine
club tremaine talked about stopping
knoxville from a deadly stunt and going
to drastic lengths to ensure it wouldn't
be done this is the only bit that i shut
down during jackass according to
tremaine the plan was to have knoxville
get shot with beanbag bullets he had
purchased himself off the internet
according to tremaine knoxville found a
stuntman who was willing to well shoot
knoxville with the bullets they got as
far as drawing a target on knoxville's
stomach before tremaine proposed pumping
the brakes
and i'm like hold on like
i want to shoot one before we let's test
it let's test this
from there they grabbed a watermelon and
a piece of plywood to use as target
practice with one of the three rounds
knoxville had purchased the watermelon
did not survive it just didn't move the
watermelon just went right through the
watermelon right through the plywood
behind
tremain was concerned so decided to next
test the beanbag bullets against two
pieces of plywood ending with the same
result according to the director the
jackass poster boy didn't even bat an
eye saying look we only have one more
we're here let's just do it tremaine
made a last stand and replied that he
was taking the cameras denying knoxville
the opportunity to blow his guts out for
the audience at home first grown-up
decision i made
this may have been one occasion where
the voice of reason did win the day but
there was another instance where
knoxville did find himself on the
receiving end of a firearm it was a feat
that became one of the first daring
steps into making jackass the world
famous phenomenon we know it to be today
the difference here was the added and
unorthodox protection used during the
stunt during an extensive oral history
shared with the hollywood reporter the
jackass team talked about one of their
deadliest stunts that had it gone wrong
would have ended their iconic journey
before it even began it saw knoxville
testing pepper spray a taser gun and a
38 caliber handgun on himself in a
self-defense study thankfully some
safety measures were taken knoxville
explained i found the cheapest
bulletproof vest they had on the market
when the time came for knoxville to pull
the trigger on himself since no one else
wanted to do it tremaine admitted we
started getting cold feet about the
bulletproof vest that was so scary to me
especially because he got the cheapest
one on the market as extra reassurance
the director wedged in a stack of
magazines behind the bulletproof vest
and then the test was on knoxville later
said of the experience it's like someone
took a shovel and hit you in the chest
as hard as they could
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies and tv shows are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]
you